the oculus rift HTC vive and PlayStation  VR are all on the playing field now but  what sort of VR games should we be  expecting John Carmack pioneer game  developer in current CTO of oculus is  urging devs to be harder on themselves  speaking during the oculus connect event  Carmack said that VR games are currently  quote coasting on novelty he continued  we need to start judging ourselves not  on a curve but in an absolute sense can  you do something in VR that has the same  value or more value than what these  other non VR things have done as for  what's next for carmax team the oculus  touch controller is set to release on  December 6th pre-orders for the  controllers are open now but you have to  order before october 27th to get  priority status stay tuned to gamespot  for more coverage once the controller is  released and for all the biggest VR news  you're already in the right place